la censure il y a le texte de loi qui a
dit la censure est abolie en France il
ne pourra plus jamais être établie c'est
beau ça c'est qu'on a Déclaration des
droits de l'homme mais enfin tout le
monde sait que c'est pas vrai
origine de force jusque vous jouez
toujours au 421
encore
[Rires]
c'est vrai j'ai joué mon premier mariage
au 421 4216
je pense que ma dette a été payée
c'était c'était quelqu'un de gentil mais
c'était tellement bête de ma part
en publiant des livres on peut avoir les
pires problèmes moi ça me semble insensé
ça moi ça me semblait et je crois que
c'est un petit peu pour ça que
effectivement j'ai eu tous ces problèmes
mais c'était en 68 et c'était une époque
où la censure c'est montrer
particulièrement vigilant en matière
d'ouvrage érotiques et comme j'avais
décidé j'avais pas décidé d'ailleurs
j'ai publié par hasard un livre d'Aragon
qui s'appelait le pont d'Irène et ce
livre à d'Aragon a été saisi dans les 48
heures et à partir de là la police m'a
demandé ce que j'avais l'intention de
faire j'ai dit je continue mais j'avais
pas les moyens à continuer j'avais pas
du tout d'argent ça a été
[Musique]
une blague un peu un peu ça sera encore
possible aujourd'hui c'est encore
possible que je peux vous signaler des
cas à l'heure actuelle vous avez un
garçon qui a écrit l'anse de Dionysos
dont le livre a été saisi et qui
poursuivit pour le trajet bonheur le
livre était l'année dernière
les gens ne savent pas parce que ça ça
n'arrange personne la censure il y a le
texte de loi qui a dit la censure est
abolie en France ne pourra plus jamais
être établi c'est beau ça c'est qu'on a
Déclaration des droits de l'homme mais
enfin tout le monde sait que c'est pas
vrai la censure évidemment elle n'est
pas en France n'est pas celle qu'il y a
au Chili n'est pas celle qu'il y a dans
dans des dictatures mais elle existe
elle est sournoise il y a l'autosens qui
fait que dans la presse on ne vous parle
pas de certaines choses
on passe sous silence un certain nombre
de trucs
alors tout le monde à l'époque vous avez
subi quoi vous avez perdu votre droit
civiques par exemple c'est vrai
perdu
c'est vrai que vous avez des problèmes
vous allez chez les visites en ligne
c'est de la légende c'est la vie privée
non c'est pas la légende c'est vrai
quand je veux pas bien
je vais dans les cours elle savait pas
que c'était vous quand même à l'époque
si elles avaient su je ne serai pas
restée là-bas
quand on a entendu parler c'était le
cahier voler non c'était les le premier
c'était le blanchi et mais le cahier
volé
certains succès et c'est surtout je l'ai
appris mais il y a pas tellement
longtemps c'est un best-seller dans les
bibliothèques de lycées
je crois que c'est parce que c'est un
livre qui raconte l'amour adolescent que
les adolescents
et pu se passer comme ça et vous vous
avez dans la suite de votre vie ou
d'autres aventures comme ça avec des
jeunes filles ou c'était simplement une
aventure adolescente
j'étais pas très vite très âgée j'avais
une vingtaine d'années mais c'est
c'était pas vraiment je sais pas mon
truc non je préfère les hommes je mets
la Nelly en question
[Musique]
que j'ai pas perdu de vue je continue
tous les jours dans la maison d'édition
alors
oui notre cheveux c'était fini quand on
travaillait ensemble il y avait plus
d'histoire d'amour entre nous
avons
on dit que vous achetez vos bas dans des
dans des magasins pour ecclésiastiques
c'est vrai vous savez ça devient plus en
plus rare les magasins pour avec les
esprits
il ne reste plus qu'une malheureusement
boutique qui vend des vêtements pour les
religieux mais comme religieuse
elle-même ne porte plus l'uniforme
j'espère que si j'espère que vous étiez
déjà comme ça les années 70 à l'époque à
l'époque Baba vous étiez déjà sexy quoi
je ne sais pas si j'étais sexy mais en
tout cas je m'habiller de cette façon là
à ceux dans une petite question de
longueur c'est plus ou moins long parce
qu'on les époque
on peut publier deux livres il y en a un
c'est Dominique vicieux la passion du
peintre Vannes
remarquable
de tous les livres que j'ai publié c'est
un livre remarquable j'ai rarement
rencontré un écrivain une aussi haute
tenue littéraire
de fond si vous voulez le l'histoire est
tout à fait tout à fait dedans vraiment
s'il y a un livre que je recommande pour
les amoureux de fantastique d'une
littérature dérangeante et poétique
c'est toujours comment la littérature
pour publier des livres
si en ce moment on a beaucoup de mal à
trouver des textes qui
excitant enfin je dirais que c'est tant
pour l'esprit
donc
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Delorme vous
avez publié à 10 ans d'intervalles ça et
c'est parce que je crois en lui
apparemment je suis la seule façon
après celui-là je l'ai lu c'est
diapositive Marcelo alors c'est un
Médecin sans Frontières espèces de
Kouchner quoi c'est ça non non c'est une
sorte enfin si vous voulez c'est un
médecin sans voiture c'est une sorte de
de baroudeur il est moins médiatisé que
que Bernard Kouchner mais c'est facile
mais c'est une grande gueule c'est un
homme sur le terrain courageux ça fait
une dizaine d'années qu'il accomplit je
sais pas combien de missions mais comme
il parle quand même plusieurs fois par
an il était arrivé de rester une année
sur le terrain moi je suis assez
admirative de ces gens j'aimerais avoir
le courage de faire ça et d'ailleurs je
désespère pas
imaginez ça aurait pu arriver quand même
oui alors j'aurais aimé être une sainte
j'aurais aimé Thérèse de villa où il y a
du tout et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu